even in the age of video games pinball
remains one of America's great pastimes
its popularity has bounced around over
the years but in the last decade the
number of international tournaments has
climbed from the hundreds into the
thousands while attendance at the events
has risen more than fivefold pinball's
popularity dates back to the 1930s and
there's one special place where you can
flip back in time and see its evolution
for these kids in Alameda California
this is day camp
welcome everybody to week five of season
seven
later that night it's the adults who
meet for league night competing for
bragging rights and the chance of a
world pinball player ranking there was
no place to play pinball back in 2002
Michael she's changed that starting in
this 350 square foot room what were the
early days like in this room it was kind
of a backdoor speakeasy kind of thing it
was called lucky juju pinball back then
open just one night a week it was bring
your own beer five bucks in the jar and
become play pinball till midnight it was
just a Saturday night thing I wasn't
gonna get a business license it wasn't
really a business so how did you then go
about building from just having the 16
machines or so to creating what we're in
today well I had a bad habit that's
buying a lot of pinball machines
she spot his first pinball machine at
age 14 by the time he had 36 he figured
he'd better do something with them I
started researching well there's got to
be a pinball museum and I looked and
looked but there wasn't really a museum
found out nobody was doing any
preservation on any of the pinball's
there were commercial commodities that
we were gonna toss into the dumpster but
I thought this is a really important
part of American
it shouldn't just be discarded like that
with that the Pacific pinball museum was
born and she took it one step further
people that come here come to something
they may think is an arcade but what
they're getting instead is a lesson in
what a lesson in art lesson in history a
lesson in physics and a lesson in
engineering and you get to play pinball
and you get to play pinball yeah through
purchases and donations there are now
more than a thousand machines in the
museum's collection about a hundred are
on display spanning more than a century
of the games history we have games in
here as early as 1887 all the way up to
the late 70s manager Darcy Bruno gave us
a tour of the museum which includes an
old Bagatelle the french precursor to
the modern game it's kind of built along
the lawn bowling sort of croquet things
you can see kind of wickets and little
holes these are all the 30s which were
outlawed across the country after the
Great Depression because they were
affiliated with gambling so we get a lot
of our older customers were like I was
never allowed to play pinball
and this Humpty Dumpty from 1947 is the
first to feature flippers that players
could control which is the crazy thing
because you don't think of pinball not
having fun that's the whole point is
that you can go in in place as the game
evolved so did the techniques to master
it because it is a game of skill you
know the lights and the arrows and
things really tell you where you should
be hitting the boss okay that wasn't
there that wasn't all right now this is
your nuts oh yeah and then this is one
of the most popular games
upper deck okay so one button launches
the ball hit ball in the back this is
your game Dana
we stopped by gorg are the first talking
machine from 1979 before entering the
modern room every back glass is kind of
a little snapshot of American culture so
you can go through the whole history of
pinball and get a pretty good idea where
America is coming from most of the
museum's collection is in storage and
selectively brought out for show and
play when we visited it featured pinball
artists arts Denholm the idea is not to
have you know fill the place with
pinball machines but more like New York
MoMA you know where they rotate art in
it's not feasible to have every promoter
that I'd say more than 250 machines
available for play and why would you
want to it'd be crazy maintaining so
many vintage machines is one of the
biggest challenges like a broken flipper
on this C which game the museum relies
on volunteers like Mike Harris
or as the Silicon Valley software
engineer is known here Google Mike what
is it that draws you to the games it's a
good question I don't know honestly I
like working on them more than I like
playing them you know I enjoy playing
them but I came here for this social
somebody could go hang out play in a
softball league or someone else would
say I'm gonna go to trivia night at the
bar is that what this is for you oh yeah
totally
that says Darcy Bruno is the key to the
game's longevity pinball really brings
people together it can be alone you can
be with friends you can be old you can
be young everybody can play pinball kind
of fun it doesn't take brains or brawn
it's just you know how well do you know
gravity and which way the ball is gonna
go it was so much fun can I tell you to
actually get back and play and the idea
that there you give 20 bucks you get to
play as many games as you want they're a
non-profit and they're leasing their
space so they'd love to have an actual
space that was theirs to call their own
and maybe they can display a few more
machines but I'm telling you really fun
afternoon I'm happy to give them my 20
bucks yeah yeah yeah I'm curious I
assuming that videogames assured in the
demise of the pinball but what brought
it back they had a rise in it as people
sort of gravitated back towards the past
this idea of something vintage
and there are people now that are
looking to try to find a way to connect
it to have interconnectivity so that you
could play pinball anywhere and then
have all of those scores up so people
could join together has so much fun